now the rest of the race News Pakistan's
prime minister has met with Iran's
president in Tehran the meeting between
Imran Khan and Hassan rouhani came as
Pakistan hopes to act as a mediator
between Iran and Saudi Arabia Pakistani
officials say they want to correct
misunderstandings between the two
countries Khan is set to travel to
Riyadh on Tuesday well at a press
conference a short while ago can't
emphasize that Pakistan will do what it
can to avoid a conflict in the region
there are news our neighbor dies with
Iran grew long way back Saudi Arabia has
been one of our closest friends Saudi
Arabia has helped us when we have needed
when when we have been a need and so the
reason for this trip that we do not want
a conflict between Saudi Arabia and Iran
we recognize that it's a complex issue
we recognize that but we feel that this
can be resolved through dialogue live
now to Tehran Al Jazeera's asset beg is
there I said what came out of these
talks then today well the Imran Khan in
that sand bar you just played this said
that Saudi Arabia has held Pakistan in a
time of need and what he's talking about
is the six billion dollar loan that
Saudi Arabia gave to Pakistan following
that investment conference inside Arabia
last year that Imran Khan attended
despite world leaders boycotting me over
the killing of journalist Jamal [ __ ] now
what came out was that in Ron cotton
praised Iran's talked about the strong
ties that Iran has with Pakistan thanked
Iran for its support of the kashmiris
8,000,000 Kashmiris but also said that
look we do not want a conflict in this
region that any conflict will have
global impacts and he said that Pakistan
isn't a mediator they want to be a
facilitator and this is a Pakistani net
initiative that no one has asked
Pakistan to do this so Imran Khan is
doing this off his own back but
President rouhani also spoke and he said
that any country that thinks
can cause instability in the region
without having the response is greatly
mistaken he said that things can be can
be agreed through dialogue but but Yemen
is a starting point that there should be
an immediate ceasefire there and some
humanitarian assistance we also spoke
about the missile attack that Iran says
the Iranian the Iranian oil tanker was
targeted on Friday and he said that they
have some evidence and they will let
that be known shortly but president
Ronnie also mentioned the sanctions the
Jaya and said that the United States
should return to the jcpoa 2015 nuclear
agreement and the sanctions should be
lifted and that's because Imran Khan
said whilst he was at the United Nations
General Assembly Donald Trump asked him
to talk or mediate between Iran and the
United States could this iniciative acid
that the Prime Minister talks about lead
to the possibility of Pakistan hosting
talks between Iran and Saudi Arabia
that's a strong possibility because Iran
has said that they're welcome
negotiation and dialogue that good
gestures will be met with a good
gestures and Pakistan is trying very
hard to arrange some sort of mediate
mediation because before Imran Khan's
set off for New York to the United
Nations General Assembly he made a
stopover in Riyadh to meet sadly Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman and he's
going to be heading there next week
again to speak to the Crown Prince so if
the Iranians agree and if Saudi Arabia
are keen to have some sort of talks it
could mean that Pakistan facilitate that
arrange or host these talks which could
lead to some sort of stability in the
region because tensions have been high
especially since their temper four teams
after that attack on the Saudi Aramco
facility that the Yemeni Houthi rebels
claimed responsibility for but Saudi
Arabia blamed Iran there's been tensions
over oil tankers attacks on oil tankers
and the build-up of US military in the
region and Pakistan was very clear on
Congress very clear that they do not
want a
in the region he mentioned the
instability in Syria you mentioned the
instability in Afghanistan and the lives
that Pakistan has lost over the last 50
years and to the war on terror
so Pakistan is very keen Imran Khan is
very keen to make these talks happen to
mediate or facilitate and if Saudi
Arabia and Iran agreed that's a very
likely possibility al Jazeera SAS had
big reporting live there from Tehran I
said many thanks Saudi Arabia and Iran
have been at odds for decades Iran is
largely a Shia nation while Saudi Arabia
sees itself as the leading Sunni voice
in the region Iran's rising influence in
Iraq after the fall of Saddam Hussein in
2003 is seen as a threat by Riyadh while
Tehran
support for Syria's President Bashar
al-assad s worst intentions and in Yemen
Houthi rebels fighting the Saudi UAE
coalition have claimed several attacks
inside Saudi Arabia they're seen as
being supported by Iran which iran
denies Abdullah Barbuda is a visiting
professor with the Middle East Institute
at the National University of Singapore
he says there are high hopes for this
diplomatic effort from Pakistan all of
us in the region and also at the global
level could ill afford to have another
conflict and in the Gulf we know how
costly this could be we know how long
that could be and also what effect it
could have on the global energy security
and global economy so I think the two
sides seem to be ready for it
Iran has always signaled that it is
ready to talk and we have seen also a
change in tone from Saudi Arabia that
they are happy to talk so I think the
visit of Imran Khan could be a
face-saving arrangement for both sides
to talk and I think all the hopes are
actually pinned on this visit that we
could avoid another conflict in the
region